jeden abend um 19 uhr schließt monika
till die tore der gärtnerei
dann haben sie und ihr mann das
gewächshaus ganz für sich allein
unter solchen glasdächern gedeihen
normalerweise tulpen obst oder tropen
pflanzen aber monika und thomas zielen
haben sich hier ihr zuhause eingerichtet
ein steinhaus im glashaus quasi dass man
nochmal eine schützende hülle übersicht
spürt und das hört es ist durchaus auch
angenehm
besonders wenn dann der regen da oben
drauf trommelt kann man trotzdem raus
ins grüne
frühes aufstehen ist bei den teams
alltag schon um 6 uhr frühstücken sie in
einer umgebung wie im botanischen garten
das familie thiel im gewächshaus wohnt
wissen auch viele kunden
wir machen eigentlich deswegen personal
da ja aber die kundschaft vor der tür
stehen zu lassen wäre für thomas ziel
undenkbar
deswegen bedient er die frau sofort
die kunden wissen ja auch man ist ja
ständig präsent das einzig positive
wahrscheinlich man spart sich den
arbeitsweg also kostengünstig zwischen
den pflanzen wohnen die tz auf 120
quadratmetern das sind wir im grünen
bereich unseres wohnzimmers angelangt
was hier wächst ja verschiedenes man
sieht dabei etwas weiter als in der
freien natur weil im glashaus natürlich
geschützter standort schwarz holz bambus
eine sache die bei uns nicht winterhart
ist hat auch im winter ganz schön jetzt
gelitten wird sich aber erholen
dann haben wir hier die glanz mispel
eine immergrüne pflanze die viele aus
italien aus mediterranen ländern kennen
ebenso die handball wächst also auch in
der freien natur in italien bereits
täglich neben dem arbeitsplatz
aufzuwachen daran hat sich monika zählt
längst gewöhnt
irgendwo ist das schon der schutzhülle
also so offen meines ist ein offenes
haus und wir führend offenes haus und
trotzdem dadurch dass es ist schon
gegliedert also es ist nicht so dass
derzeit permanent auch die angestellten
ja hinten sind in dem privat teil da
gibt es schon
das passiert aber es ist hässlich im
rahmen im sommer steigen die
temperaturen unter dem glas auf mehr als
40 grad celsius
dann spenden jalousien schatten wir
lassen es normalerweise im sommer dann
bei seinen ganzen tag geschlossen oder
teilweise geschlossen dass man das
einschätzen
also jetzt gerade wie eine leichte
bewölkung da können wir so einen spalt
auf lassen
dann hält man sie auch noch aus das geht
schon stichwort klima wie arbeitet es
sich in einem betrieb in dem der chef
nur wenige meter vom tresen seine dusche
hat es ist eine setzen sehr privates und
der familie ausfällt ist was wir auch
mit number im kollektiv und dem chefs
haben aber bei chefs mal der haussegen
schief hängt das kriegt halt auch mit
insofern ist es halt wirklich alles sehr
sehr live sehr authentisch sehr echt
1993 nahmen die teils allen mut zusammen
um sich ihren wohn und arbeitsraum zu
erfüllen
beide wussten was sie wollten streit ums
konzept gab es nicht die gewaltige
investition von mehreren hunderttausend
euro hat sich gelohnt auch wenn der bau
harte arbeit bedeutete und viel
bereitschaft zum risiko in klassischen
gärtnerei geschäft ist die konkurrenz
wegen der vielen baumärkte und
discounter hart monika t arbeitet als
vertriebs angestellte von zu hause
einkaufen gehen muss sie nur selten es
wirkte alles vor oder hinter der haustür
man kommt nicht ganz um hin da ab und zu
doch was zu kaufen aber wir versuchen
schon die ressourcen die hier natürlich
da sind zu nutzen das ist uns schon
bewusst dass deutlich besser ist als
support qualität die wir hier finden
und die nachbarn bereits in der bauphase
fünften einige die nase
die jungen unternehmer waren ihnen
suspekt und sind es bis heute aber den
pilz macht das wenig aus
sowas ja kannst du mit essen
sie schöpfen ihre kraft aus der natur
die sie umgibt jeden tag aufs neue